Salut ! Aujourd'hui on est mardi, et le mardi je fais un tour à quelqu'un.
Un truc pour vous bluffer !
Alors forcément j'ai un volontaire désigné.
Le volontaire est Edouard Cambus !
-Bonjour.
Alors Edouard est producteur de spectacle, il produit "Les coups de boost de l'humour" et pleins d'autres choses.
Et il est venu à la maison.
Et aujourd'hui il y a une grande nouvelle, un anniversaire,
un anniversaire que vraiment je voulais souhaiter...
Joyeux anniversaire à Loft Story !
-Bon anniversaire à Loft Story...
La tête dépitée. Il faut vraiment qu'on leur souhaite un bon anniversaire à eux ?
Je suis allé chez un pote qui était abonné à la fameuse chaîne où l'on pouvait
regarder 24h/24.
Et tu regardais il n'y avait rien et dès qu'il y avait une scène intéressante ils filmaient un pot de fleurs.
A l'époque quand ils ont lancé le concept de Loft Story, il y avait 38 000 personnes qui voulaient y participer.
Alors qu'ils ne connaissaient pas l'émission.
Il y en a eu 13 qui étaient sélectionnés et 2 qui sont parti très très vite d'ailleurs...
Après c'est très intéressant !
Steeve est devenu chroniqueur
Loana...
elle remonte la pente.
Doucement.
Jean Edouard est devenu consultant artistique dans un hôtel cinq étoiles.
Ils ont tous fait un truc après.
Je te projette en arrière, 15 ans en arrière dans Loft Story.
Tu fais parti des 38 000 qui passent le casting.
Tu es sélectionné. Tu es le quatorzième candidat.
Et tu vas faire tes 70 jours dans Loft Story.
-J'aurai peut être fait de la piscine.
Je suis dans la piscine, vous venez quand vous voulez, je vous attend !
Tu fais tes 70 jours, il se passent des choses... c'est-à-dire pas grand chose !
En effet, il ne s'est jamais passé grand chose dans le Loft.
C'est ça ! On aurait du l'appeler Jean Edouard Campus. J'ai failli l'appeler Jean Edouard.
Donc Edouard Cambus, 15 ans après le Loft, je vous retrouve ici chez moi pour le MentalVlog.
Evidemment, on se souvient de votre sortie qui était exceptionnelle sur les Champs Elysées.
On se souvient, ça criait, ça hurlait "Edouard Cambus !"
"Edouard Cambus ! Edouard Cambus !"
Et bien il est là, j'ai cette chance là !
Edouard Cambus, ça s'est bien passé la sortie du Loft ?
-Oui.
On se souvient, il y avait de la folie, des paparazzis, et on vous a vu nulle part...
Et comme on vous a vu nulle part, vous avez du reprendre un métier.
J'aimerai maintenant que tu imagines le métier que tu ferai après le Loft.
Là je te parle sérieusement cette fois-ci.
Imagine un métier que tu pourrais faire après le Loft.
Alors évidemment ne prends pas producteur puisque tu fais ce métier.
Donc tu choisis le métier que tu veux. Ça peut être taxidermiste ou encore chauffeur de bus, peu importe.
Ça y est ? Tu as un métier en tête ?
-Oui, j'en ai un.
D'accord.
C'est un métier que tu as déjà fais pour de vrai ?
-Oui.
Oui ? D'accord.
Rien que ça, ça l'agace déjà !
"Mais comment il sait ça ?!"
Bon évidemment je ne connais pas ta vie alors je ne sais pas quel métier tu as pu faire comme métier.
Par contre je vais essayer de t'imaginer en situation.
Alors imagine-toi dans ta tête en train de pratiquer ce métier.
Est-ce-que tu peux décroiser les bras ? C'est bien.
Tu t'imagines juste en train de pratiquer l'action que nécessite ce métier.
Tu imagines des choses dans la pièce.
Passe-toi le film de ce métier là.
D'accord. Tu regardes à plusieurs endroits différents...
Ok. Donc ça se passe plutôt dans une grande salle. Ça ne se passe pas dans un bureau...
-Oui, c'est correct.
Tu te dandines un peu... donc c'est un métier en mouvement.
Tu dois être debout en permanence. C'est correct ?
-C'est correct.
Est-ce-que.... Tiens j'ai peut-être une piste...
Je pense avoir une piste.
Ne regarde pas ce que j'écris, regarde la caméra.
Je pense que ça doit être ça...
Est-ce-que tu peux me dire quel métier tu as choisi de faire, après être sorti de ce Loft Story virtuel ?
-Serveur.
Tu as décidé de devenir serveur ?
Serveur !
-C'est toujours bluffant !
On a bon !
-Très très bluffant !
-C'est frustrant, mais c'est génial !
J'adore voir les têtes comme ça une fois qu'on a fini le tour.
Merci à toi d'avoir participé, d'avoir joué l'expérience et d'avoir joué le jeu mentalement parce que sans toi je ne pouvais pas le faire.
Ne cherchez pas à comprendre, ce n'est pas le but de cette vidéo
le but de cette vidéo c'est déjà de vous divertir, de sortir un nouveau tour et de faire ça sur quelqu'un !
Merci à toi ! Tu fais "les coups de boost de l'humour."
Je vais vous mettre dans le descriptif le lien pour "les coups de boost de l'humour"
c'est un plateau d'artistes.
Si cette mentalisation sur Edouard vous a plu, vous pouvez nous le faire savoir en laissant un petit...
pouce en l'air !
Vous pouvez également vous abonner à la chaîne, laissez un petit commentaire et nous on se retrouve demain à 17H pour le prochain MentalVlog.
Ciao !